welcome to this video veera veera ah
what do i do ok first move your head
serves 10 second tolerance so you can
can consider a little bit I had some
good results with this weird winner of a
sub variation with b6 check that people
seem to not know so I'm going to try it
again oops I did it again ok well not
oops no it was on purpose ok that
doesn't seem very threatening to me to
be perfectly honest you know they'd
simply don't know how to play that white
has to play with some pressure against
the h5 point but yeah this guy also
didn't go for that so yeah yeah I'm very
comfortable already with them the
excellent structure that that black
enjoys let's see yeah I can even play
Queen to e7 and ask him a very very
embarrassing question about the about
the H pawn ok he has King age 3 which
looks really ugly but might be possible
night he has also interesting yeah let's
do that Queen g7 looks mm-hmm quite
risky thats same
came Knight to f5 this was the idea of
course the h-bond is some is an issue
okay he mmm it seems that he doesn't
mind to sacrifice it or what is the idea
Queen a six maybe yeah that's possible
ok I don't I really don't have to take
at the moment I mean I already have made
some very nice strategic gains so it's
not that I need this this rather
unimportant porn
okay let's let's just check for one
moment I can also take first hmm
let's get us make sure that this is
going away the good thing is here just
here I just have to trade Queens and I'm
winning the game it's very very easy
plan but how to how to get this in oh
it's not really concerned about some
things I thought that a six would be a
threat here okay about threat is a bit
much but I thought you would do
something against it but didn't okay Oh
Bishop c5 mm-hmm ok I understand maybe
this wasn't the best timing ever and I
played that a bad bit too early right I
played that too early Bishop c5 is very
very inconvenient oh no not good not
good at all mmm King am King 87
hmm can now that was okay a 6 I really
are now that I'm miss evaluated
something I really overestimated this
idea i had much more time to do that
Oh
yeah rook a 1 rupee a one I have King b7
quindi frequency for okay so Queen to a
three or what probably
yeah sure it's I mean I really don't
think that he has something but it is it
looks scary I think that probably an
engine would defend this pretty pretty
easily but I don't know it looks kind of
scary should a Phi for some crazy move
yeah maybe it is a dangerous attack
check for rugby six Wow okay i go back
to be seven am i getting killed they
don't know ja ja Shaima with his a cig
stuff it was a really an excellent
position that i had time morning
Jeff cannot defend this nonsense let's
check your not check check yeah okay
black reasons ah that was disappointing
yeah Roger yeah this is this is just
excellent yeah I have to just have to be
precise so who'd besides the fact that a
4-h for could have been taken all the
time I mean this is certainly possible
but I was just thinking this is this is
strategically winning but okay yes this
kind of he can try to do stuff here on
the queenside which is not going to work
but it can work if you play it down as
badly as I did yeah a six is just an
idiotic move I was really thinking this
is a good idea intending b5 shutting
things down but then you can take and
it's really a bad idea to put the poor
on a 6cm this really is a bad idea you
should probably start with quincy form
assembly don't believe that I mean white
is reduced to the idea of checkmate
everything else is just losing the game
and I don't think black will get
checkmated if he is playing at them in
some some kind of sensible way like here
start with this one key point is that
also if he takes I can sometimes just
take with the ape horn and it's actually
that's much better that's very much
better I also can sometimes just go go
back with the king I have to do this
kind of thing a six is just very stupid
I mean I really don't know how it is
objectively because I still think that
should be okay
but maybe I should have really get done
something entirely different him here
when I went when I went went to this I
was thinking that um maybe maybe I
should just do something like this and
give away this porn like luck here go
for this position this is this is an
idea because some it has stopped the
tech forum for the moment and well I
mean this is still a very good structure
but it's a bit now if this is necessary
yeah 86 was a mistake simply it really
was a mistake this is some difficult to
play at least as we as we saw here King
b7 here yeah well okay i am ok they're
here here i had a very very big chance
that I did not see at all computer
points out g5 and black winners really
with the win yeah okay i mean i saw i
saw this idea of course that I can do
this counter check but I thought okay
here I hey Jeff a draw here with 93 I
didn't really think of a drawer I was
still pretty optimistic here that I
should be able to fend off this attack
okay but g5 is winning okay interesting
you know okay this I understand that
this is quite dangerous check yeah I'm
all of a sudden winning it in the check
amazingly check checkmate sure that's
curious
yeah maybe I should have thought about
this Queenie to for a moment longer so
that that then maybe you can spot g5
this um he has to play rugby to hear
what is the difference exactly there is
no difference so this means why it is
already in trouble okay oh yeah I don't
know g5 I didn't see that one check okay
and after this this is this it gets
tricky yeah Queen f5 after that I'm just
losing that is spotted b5 is still okay
I it's difficult to to defend in a
practical game it's simply simply not so
easy yeah if I simply have to move I
cannot I mean be five its losing but i
have no move to cover b6 it just lost
yeah what did i'm i think this is this
is really okay and it's not much to say
them five now I didn't want to do this
because of a six this is often a problem
if you would get in a six then it would
be great you have to block the Queen
side but he has a six and this makes
things very tricky now thats it sets so
totally okay really you can argue you
can argue that you can also go here
actually now that that's an ID action
that's interesting especially in a
situation that is pretty good on the
Kings side where the King side is not
opened quickly Oh at all yes it's really
nice you know something like that suit
so it's very difficult to play this is
position
even if you basically have achieved
everything that you want I mean it is
simply a big burden for wide that any
end game loses yeah with this structure
and this is why I'm very optimistic yeah
and just have to avoid King checkmated
and then I'm probably winning this thing
but I am I got checkmated okay thanks
for watching